hello everyone and welcome to another
one of the most awaited encounters from
the ftx crypto cup the preliminaries
it's daniel double versus magnus carlsen
at the doom of not doing all that great
he really needs a win
uh to try and get back into the upper
field of the competition to
to qualify for the main event and magnus
doing relatively okay
uh but dubo has the white pieces and uh
well if we know dubof he is going to try
something pretty crazy and
well if you've seen the thumbnail you
know what's happening here
so uh without further ado let's check it
out it's uh duba with the white pieces
and he opens with
d4 and this game uh holds a special
significance since their uh head-to-head
score
is nine wins ten draws and the 9 losses
each so whoever wins this game will
emerge a victory for the moment
until they meet for the next time of
course
uh so after d4 we have d5 uh c4 by
dubois and now the immediate c5 by
magnus the so-called
austrian variation of the queen's gambit
we have knight to f3
and now c captures on the for double
grabs on d5
we have knight to f6 and now uh winning
back the pawn
knight captures on d4 queen captures on
the e5 and
now knight to c3 attacking uh carlson's
queen here
we have queen to a5 and here there are
many moves that have been played in this
position but
the one that the dub of plays has only
been played once
and it has been played once by himself
he played it against mamidyarov
and that is this e4 move and while
capturing an e4
is the strongest move uh that is exactly
what mama yarov did and the duo
won that game very nicely but magnus not
interested in going into such lines uh
he simply ignores this the the way you
play this is basically if the pawn is
accepted
then we go into this bishop to b5 check
bishop to d7 and queen to b3 line
and then it's just um a pretty crazy
position where anything can happen for
example we could trade captures captures
uh and if captures knight captures here
and for example if a6 just keep
kicking away the knight knight to d4 and
while this
is okay you kind of neglected your
development as black maybe a little bit
and even though you're up material
i maybe not something to uh try your
chain
chances on uh against a player like dubo
so instead of this after e4 magnus plays
bishop to d7 he simply declines the pawn
and it is now already as of move 7 that
we have a completely new
new game so let's see how duba deals
with this
new insolence that is rejecting the pawn
so bishop to d7 and now
bishop to d2 uh magnus dubo could also
try to play something like knight to b3
kick away the queen and
try developing this way but he's
thinking why
uh why move the knight back since it's
doing such a nice job on d4 so here
bishop to d2
and now knight that's in that's another
knight knight to c6 offers uh
a trade here and magnus did spend a lot
of time here dubois has some 13 minutes
on the clock
whereas magnus has nine minutes on the
clock and now
uh he goes knight uh d to b5 uh you
could also try to do some sort of a
discovery with
this knight but uh for the moment there
aren't any if you go some like knight b5
attack the queen the queen can just go
back
and from the 8 you cover the c7 square
nothing to worry about here
so instead we have knight d to b5 uh now
preparing moves like knights to d5
because then both of the knights will be
attacking the c7 pawn
to give you an example uh whatever you
could
try something like uh
for example maybe just uh
playing e6 or something then we go
knights to d5 and then
the the queen is under attack you have
to move the queen but then also knights
the c7 check happens and the y just wins
the game on the spot
uh but okay magnus just goes uh rook to
c8 he keeps the queen on a5 he says
there's no rush nothing is happening
here
and now uh rook to c1 now if you go
this then uh for example knight uh to d5
then queen can just go back and yes the
knights are attacking c7
but the rook and queen are defending it
and for those of you who are maybe new
to chess
maybe you're thinking but yeah we can
just win the rook by giving check no you
can't really do this because then you
give two knights for a rook and that's
uh
never a good idea and when i say never i
mean almost never
so here instead after rook the c8 we
have rook to c1
after rook the c8 and then now comes e5
by magnus he still keeps
the queen on a5 saying uh you don't
really have anything here i'm just gonna
develop my dark square bishop
castle and enjoy my extra pawn
so here dubo goes bishop the c4 which is
uh
another very aggressive idea of putting
the the bishop on c4 like this
in front of the rook but again there are
no good discoveries with the knight so
here we have a6
and now before just moving the knight
because you really don't want to move
this knight to a3 and allow bishop
captures on a3 this would only
uh improve black's development here we
have knight to d5
finally attacking carlson's queen on a5
queen has to go back to d8
this is the only uh good move the only
reasonable move
uh and now the knight retreats the c3
and here
uh magnus again not rushing with the the
development of
the the bishop or castle or anything
goes knight to d4 just grabs this
uh beautiful square for his bishop and
it comes with tempo as the bishop on b3
is under attack
so here bishop back to b3 and now
knight captures on d5 with bishop
captures and now
bishop to c6 again uh he says there's
time for everything there's no
need to castle just yet so here he wants
to trade down even further
as uh the the more pieces duba has the
more uh
well the the more he's going to be up in
in development and
maybe it's going to be easier for him to
create some sort of an attack against
carlson's uncastled king so here we have
castles and now
bishop to c5 we have queen to g4
nubo goes after the the g7 pawn and you
have to be careful you can't
defend it with something like queen to
f6 because the rook on c8 hangs
so here uh du magnus just castles and
now
king to h1 again duba being very very
aggressive here
uh he wants to play f4 f5 and get some
sort of an attack
going so here magnus continues with his
plan which is to just
trade because he's up a pawn so bishop
captures we have knight captures on d5
and
now he's the one that starts pushing
here with f5 and you cannot capture here
uh because the knight would hang on d5
so here uh double the
best bet is to just play the queen
somewhere
but on a light square like d1 h3 h5
however he plays queen to g5 and this
allows magnus a very uh
well nifty idea he plays f captures on
e4 and now he just
grabbed the pawn and he says okay let's
trade queens now i'm just
uh up uh uh uh up upon
uh uh it is a double pawn but
uh you know why not so here we have
queen captures an e5 dubois not
interested in that he plays a very very
tricky move
uh because now uh magnus has a move that
really
puts duo on the spot and that is of
course the move you've seen in the
thumbnail
that is rook to f5 and now what do you
do here
if you move the queen uh then just uh
we're gonna capture the knight and
that's it you lose a piece and game over
so what can do both play here there is
but one move so feel free to pause the
video here and
try to find this only move uh that is
available to do before for even just
continuing the game
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
finding the the the nicest move
in the position and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
queen captures on d4 that's that's the
good stuff and
leave it to do both to find such an idea
uh point is now
magnus captures the queen and now rook
captures in c8 and now if magnus
captures the rook then we have
knight the e7 check and then we just
pick up the queen and now it's dubo
who's up a piece so of course magnus
cannot allow this
uh after rook captures on c8 he has to
play rook captures on d5
and now comes rook captures on d8 with
check of course
rook captures uh and here dubo played
everything
correctly and uh magnus now is in a bit
of a better position
but the problem is dual now blunders
upon he plays
g3 uh creates some breeding room for his
king but he
totally disregards that his b2 pawn is
under attack
or maybe it's not a blunder maybe it's
uh some sort of a crazy tempo idea but i
seriously doubt it i think he just
forgot that his b2 pawn is under attack
uh well another reason why maybe you
should always just
put you know push your pawn to b4 but
okay here bishop captures on b2 was
played and now
bishop to f4 now magnus is uh up in
material
and uh well do both still can defend
this i mean it's only one pawn
so here we have b5 by magnus now the
problem is uh yes it's
only one pawn but magnus has a two to
one advantage on the queen side and at
some point
these pawns are going to reach all the
way here you're going to have to
exchange and then magnus will have a
pass pawn and it's not going to be easy
to defend it so here
rook to e1 dubo wants to equalize in
material
but now rook to d4 defending and now
king to g2 you don't really gain
anything by bishop to e5
because even if you exchange bishops
that only
pretty much helps black nothing really
happening here uh
even if you capture here on e4 then just
root captures on a2 and then two
connected pass pawns will be winning
so instead after rook to d4 king to g2
and
now comes rook to c4 now not even
allowing any bishop to e5 ideas
so rook to d1 and now comes a bishop
back to f6 not allowing the rook to come
to d8 we have rook to d2 and now comes
king to f7 as usual uh when in end game
bring your king to help out with
with your your plans so here we have g4
the
will start pushing on the king side now
and the bishop to d for now closing off
the d
file for white's rook so you can't
really do anything
we have rook to e2 attacking the pawn
and magnus now just plays bishop c5 now
the rook defends it
we have rook to d2 and now king to e6
uh we have h4 by double but now a5 and
the problem is
uh yes uh dubo is pushing on the king
side magnus is pushing on the queen side
but there's no way for dubo to break
through on the king's side so here
he does push h5 uh with a4 and now even
h6 and now while magnus could block it
he decides to capture he says
it's not a problem we have captures
captures and
now b4 so here b3 is coming
uh we have bishop to f4 and now b3
we have captures captures and now rook
to b2 uh defending the pawn
uh defending the it's in the b2 square
so the pawn cannot be pushed and also
preparing to capture the pawn but not
rook to not b4 but rather rook to c3 or
you could play rook to b4
uh but magnus has a different idea we
have rook to b1
and now king to d5 and he was in this
position uh animal 41 that daniel dubo
resigned the game
and a wonderful victory for for magnus
carlsen
this was a very eventful round and i've
received a lot of other suggestions as
well
so i will do my best to cover them uh as
soon as possible
uh but uh this is one one match up that
uh pretty much whenever it happens i
will show it unless it's like
like a snooze fest like you know a
arranged bomb cloud to draw or something
like that
but even then i might show it so uh who
knows but yeah for those of you who
really uh like it when i finish drawing
games
here we're gonna show the quickest way
why
uh why it would be a loss uh for double
now after
this you don't really have a good move
you have to play something you're gonna
play let's say check
we're gonna block you're gonna attack
the pawn uh we're gonna play bishop to
d4
guarded the b2 square so now we're going
to push the pawn all the way to b2 and
the white is helpless in all of this
white will play something
we're going to play b2 and then that's
it let's say king f1
rook to a3 and now we just bring the
rook to a1 and that's it
there's no stopping this if king goes
back rook a1 and now you either have to
give up the rook or trade rooks and then
black just promotes a pawn to a queen so
uh not much to be done here for white
dubo
of course knows this and that's why he
resigned the game
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
ryan urban uh akram the pilot uh william
ride out emilio carraro and siddhartha
yaya kumar for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and uh just something i forgot to to
mention when someone offers you a phone
like this it's not mandatory for you to
take it
just just you know saying but it is uh
uh it is you know polite but it's not
mandatory
so yeah see you soon